>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Paulette Hasier:
Good morning.
My name is Dr. Paulette
Hasier, and I'm the chief
of the geography and
math division here
at the Library of Congress.
I would like to welcome you
and thank you all for coming
to the Library of
Congress GIS Day Event.
We are really excited to
share the depth and breadth
of geospatial tools and data
and how they're being used
to support Congress and
how they're also being used
to support the library here.
In this morning's
session you will hear
from our esteemed Congressional
members and representatives
from the Congressional
Research Service
on how GIS data can
inform policy.
In our afternoon session, we
will treat you to a showcase
of GIS story maps and how this
tool has revolutionized the way
we support digital humanities
and digital visualization.
I would, however, be remiss
if I did not thank those
who made this day possible.
I would like to acknowledge
Congressman Takano
for taking the time out
of his busy schedule
to give us first-hand
insights on how GIS
and geospatial data is
being used in Congress.
The GIS Program would not
be possible if it was not
for the support the
of our OCIO staff,
our GI [inaudible]
staff, and our CRS staff.
Special tanks are extended to
Dr. Mary Mazanec and [inaudible]
of the Congressional
Research Service
for helping plan this day and
for speaking at the event.
A special thanks to Steve
Kelly and Kathleen Ott
at the Library Congressional
Relations Office as well
for their help and guidance.
Also a deep appreciation
for the [inaudible] staff,
especially Laurie [inaudible],
who was helpful in scheduling
and creating this event for us.
And lastly, I would like
to thank the participants
of the GIS LOC story
map pilot project,
which you'll see this afternoon,
who brought their curatorial
and special collections
expertise to the project.
And now without further ado, I'd
like to introduce Mark Sweeney,
the acting deputy director
of the Library of Congress
who will introduce
our keynote speaker,
Representative Mark Takano.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Sweeney: Good
morning, everyone.
Thank you, Paulette.
Members of Congress,
ladies and gentlemen,
on behalf of the Librarian
of Congress Dr. Carla Hayden,
it's my pleasure to
welcome to you GIS Day
at the Library of Congress.
Today's activities underscore
the increasing importance
of geospatial data to the
formulation of public policy
and execution of
legislative research.
They're also point indicative
of the dramatic changes
that are occurring
with geospatial data
and the whole field of
geographic information sciences.
Indeed, it is amazing to see
just how much policymakers,
academics, analysts are now
routinely using geospatial data
to make sense of our
increasingly complex world.
This is a change of significant
proportions, and I'm proud
to say that the Library
of Congress is right there
playing an active role.
A prime example of this is
our new platform called the
Geospatial Hosting
Environment, GHE for short.
It consists of a
series of data portals
and software packages
designed to help Congress,
the Congressional
Research Service,
and members of the
public access, understand,
and use the library's
outstanding collection of modern
and historic geospatial data.
I know you'll be hearing a lot
more about that later on today,
especially in the afternoon.
And now it is my honor
to introduce this
morning's keynote speaker,
United States Representative
Mark Takano,
who represents California's
41st District.
He represents the people of
Riverside, Moreno Valley,
Jurupa Valley, and Paris.
He serves as vice-ranking
member of the House Committee
on Veterans Affairs and is
a member of the Education
and Workforce Committee
and the Science, Space,
and Technology Committee.
It is highly noteworthy that
immediately after he was elected
to the House in 2013,
Representative Takano
and his staff enthusiastically
and effectively used geospatial
data in connection with a number
of creative policy studies.
One of them, which was
particularly ground-breaking,
used GIS data to compare
how high school funding
and household income relate
to academic performance.
I'm delighted that we are now
going to have the opportunity
to hear about some of the way
the Congressman's office has
seized upon the opportunities
of GIS data in its work.
So please join me in welcoming
Representative Mark Takano
to the podium this morning.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Takano: Well,
happy GIS Day
or geographic information
systems day.
Well, thank you for
that introduction.
And thank you to the
Library of Congress
for hosting this
wonderful event.
And it really is a pleasure
to be with you this morning,
especially among people
who get really excited
about this software,
the GIS software.
Well, on December
17th, 1903, Orville
and Wilbur Wright
achieved something
that no one thought
possible when Orville climbed
into the cockpit of a plane and
took flight for the first time
with Wilbur running
alongside him.
And on February 23rd, 1945,
just months before the end
of World War II, six United
States Marines raised an
American flag during the fierce
and tragic five-week battle
of Iwojima, symbolizing the
valor of those who fought
and conquered a fascist regime.
And on December 24th,
1968 astronaut Bill
Anders pointed his camera
out of the window of Apollo 8
and captured the Earth rising
above the moon, putting
our planet and all
of its inhabitants into
a whole new context.
But what connects
these three moments
and many others throughout
our history is
that we only know their glory,
understand their intensity,
and appreciate their beauty
because they were
captured in visual images.
The power of visual images
to communicate ideas is
so well accepted
that it's now cliche.
A picture is worth -- well,
I was going to say a
million words [inaudible].
But it does not diminish the
influence of that imagery --
it does not -- the fact
that it's a cliche does
not diminish the influence
that the images has
on our ability to see
and believe the truth
about our world.
Now, no one will mistake
the maps we create
through GIS software for iconic
photographs, but the power
of images to help people see and
believe the truth still applies.
And in a time when truth can be
hard to come by and even harder
to communicate, there has
never been a greater need
for technology that can
present information in the ways
that persuade us and inspire us.
And that is what first
led me and my office
to start using GIS
mapping software.
And it's why we continue
to use this software today.
In my first term in office
I wanted to connect with
and better understand
the business community
in my district.
And I wanted the business
community to see and understand
that I was serious
about supporting them.
So my office set
up a listening tour
that we ambitiously called
100 Businesses in 100 Days.
We didn't quite do
it in 100 days,
but we did visit 100 businesses.
I traveled around the district
asking local business owners
about their interests,
their goals, and, you know,
what kept them up at night.
And at the of the tour I
could have just listed the 100
companies I met with
and provided a short
description of each visit.
I could have written an op ed or
a newsletter announcing the end
of my tour and then
declaring my findings.
But instead, my staff
used GIS software
to build an interactive
map of all the businesses
that I had visited, accompanied
by pictures of my visits.
The simple image of a map
of our district dotted
with 100 flags representing my
stops sent an important message
that I was committed to
supporting local businesses
and to promote the growth
of our local economy.
Now, this is just one way that
GIS has helped me better serve
and communicate with
my constituents.
The software is helpful not just
in mapping the places I've been
but mapping where my
constituents are as well.
But as the vice-ranking
member of the House Committee
on Veterans Affairs, ensuring
our veterans get the care
and support they have earned
is one of my top priorities.
And it's one of the most
important issues in my district,
which has a large
veterans population.
My office can use
mapping technology to find
out where the veterans in my
district are clustered so that
when I host a veteran's event,
I know where it should be held.
We can use it to understand
where veterans live in relation
to their local VA
healthcare facility
so we can recognize issues
related to access to care
and the logistical challenge of
getting to and from facilities.
We can also use it to appreciate
the geographic distribution
of veterans by gender,
by age, and by income
so that we can target
local services to the areas
that need it the most.
Where should we host roundtables
to connect veterans
with local resources?
Where should a new VA
healthcare facility be built
to increase access to care?
Which areas in the community
have the greatest risk
of veteran homelessness?
These are all questions that
mapping software can answer.
So, you know, I'm
going to depart
from my script a little bit,
right now in the Congress
we are considering a bill.
It's called the Air
Act, which would be sort
of like a [inaudible] for
underutilized VA facilities.
But one thing I would like
to see is a clear map showing
where those facilities are
-- all the facilities are,
whether they're in red
states, blue states, rural.
I'd like to know -- you know,
we have data from Medicare
that can tell us about the
quality of care provided
by the private sector
facilities --
that should be data that we can
map against all the data VA has
about its own healthcare.
I mean, the government's
rich with data.
And one of the things that
we are, in my opinion,
is we are pretty transparent
if we have the data.
How is it we're going
to use that data?
That would be enormously
useful in a very current issue
that we have going on and might
even help us get through some
of the partisan differences.
I'll speak more about
that in a moment.
So we live in a society and an
economy that's driven by data.
Decisions about commerce,
traffic patterns,
and even baseball strategy
are increasingly using --
made by using data that did not
exist even a few decades ago.
Our systems learn and
evolve to fit our needs.
The Internet knows
my preferences
and my hobbies better than
some of my own family members.
And I'm not sure --
and I'm also sure
that I'm not alone
in that regard.
Yet when it comes to
policy-making in Congress,
that type of data-driven
thinking is almost non-existent.
Anecdotes, partisanship,
and ideology are filling
the void where data belongs.
And we're always
experiencing the consequences
of not using data.
Programs like GIS can help us
remove the partisan blinders
and see our challenges
for what they are instead
of what we want them to be.
Let me give one more example.
The common perception
of public transportation
in Southern California is
to put it kindly not great.
Because of that, the first
thing people they need to live
in my region -- that people
think they need in order to live
in my region is a car.
And because of that, public
officials are hesitant to invest
in a public transportation
system
that many folks will
not even consider using.
Now, my office built a map
of public transportation
in the district.
We found that most neighborhoods
in my community are actually
within walking distance
of a bus stop.
And we found that by
adding a few more routes
in specific areas, the public
transportation system would be
even more accessible
for a greater number
of my constituents.
Now, these small but important
insights are the difference
between lazy anecdotal thinking
that keeps us stuck in the past
and focused data-driven thinking
that can help us
redefine our future.
Now, these are the insights
that can change the way we think
of our neighborhoods, our
cities, and our country
and really can help
us make policies
that improve the
lives of our citizens.
GIS software and programs like
it put the power of imagery
to communicate complex
ideas and the power of data
to transcend our existing
biases into the hands
of members of Congress.
Now, my office continues
to provide trainings
and step-by-step instructions
for other offices so that more
of my colleagues can
use the software.
And I hope that by the next
GIS Day I'll have a handful
of members here with me
describing the innovative ways
they're using GIS to better
represent their constituents.
I truly appreciate all the
work you do to preserve
and disseminate accurate
information
to members and to the public.
And I believe -- and I
believe in your ability
to help us make better
decisions that will lead
to stronger communities
and a stronger country.
So thank you for having me
this morning, and thank you
for all your hard work.
And, again, happy GIS Day.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: Thank you very
much again, Congressman Takano,
for that excellent keynote.
My name is Tim St. Onge.
I'm with the Geography and Map
Division here at the Library
of Congress, and I'm going
to be guiding us along
in our program this morning.
So next I'm pleased to
introduce Dr. Mary Mazanec.
She is the director of the
Congressional Research Service.
And she is here with other
members of CRS's GIS team,
who will be discussing the
Congressional Research Services'
use of GIS to support Congress.
So please welcome Dr. Mazanec.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Mazanec: Good
morning, everyone.
I am very pleased to be here
today to celebrate GIS Day
at the Library of Congress.
Now, as most of you know,
the Congressional Research
Service works exclusively
for the Congress.
And we have been doing
so for over a century.
As you may know, we provide
both legal and policy analysis
on all legislative
issues to committees
and members and their staff.
And our core values -- our work
is guided by our core values,
which are authoritativeness,
confidentiality,
objectivity, and
non-partisanship.
What you probably don't know is
that we have been using GIS
technology for over 20 years.
GIS technology has
advanced significantly
in the course of
the last 20 years.
And likewise, our use of GIS in
CRS -- GIS in CRS [Laughs] --
has also evolved significantly.
We have moved from using
it ad hoc for an individual
on a desktop computer
to actually establishing a GIS
service, which supports all
of our analysts, attorneys,
and information professionals
as we do our work for Congress.
And as many of you in the
audience can appreciate,
public policy as laid out
by the Congressmen exists
within geographical boundaries.
And this makes GIS a wonderful,
fabulous tool that can be used
to effectively and
succinctly visualize
and communicate public policy
analysis and very complex ideas.
Now, I'd like to say that the
hallmark of our GIS team in CRS
and the way we do our
work is collaboration --
collaboration with those
of you in the Library
that are also using GIS and also
to our colleagues on the Hill.
It is a collaborative
partnership.
And from the CRS staff, our
team includes GIS analysts,
research librarians, policy
analysts, and graphic designers.
And we all work together to try
to produce the most informative
and best product
for the Congress.
So I'm going to stop here
and really turn the program
over to the CRS experts,
if you can join me,
who will tell you more
specifics about how we use GIS
to support the Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Calvin DeSouza:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Calvin DeSouza, and I'm
going to talk about GIS,
along with Hannah
Fischer, my coworker.
So to reiterate some of
the things that Mary said,
here at CRS, whenever we work
on a GIS request, we always want
to make sure that we find
the most authoritative data
that we can possible.
So when we do that, we pair up
with a librarian or an analyst
to start working on a topic,
which can range from any
of these topics that you
see here on the map --
not a map, on the screen.
So whenever we work with
a product, we then --
and finish it, we then take
to through a multi-separate
view process
where the results
can be anywhere
from a confidential memo to
Congressional staff or report,
or other products, or
in-person briefing, or an email,
sort of telephone
correspondence back and forth.
Topics can range from
an international issue.
So here we have a couple
examples of reference maps
that we've made for a
couple international issues.
We work with analysts,
get the appropriate data,
and we start designing
the map to make sure
that the appropriate
information is on the map
to easily convey the
information that we want.
We can also work on local
issues where we'll reach
out to the local
governments to try
to gather what we
need for the maps.
So it can really
range from anything.
We're willing to work
with you along the way.
What are our type of products?
Sometimes we make maps in
PDF's that we distribute
to you directly to
Congressional clients.
Sometimes those same
maps are in reports
that are along with
other products.
Sometimes we do GIS analysis
where the result isn't a map,
it's actually spreadsheet
of data.
So we've done all this analysis,
and here are the results of it
in a tabular format that you
can use for other products.
Some Congressional staff,
they're pretty tech-savvy,
and now more people with
the GHE, we have access
to RJS and RJS Online.
So sometimes some staff want
to do the analysis themselves.
So they don't know where
to get started with data.
So we can gather the data
for them, package it up,
and give it to them so they
can get their analysis started.
And we're happy to
announce that we're getting
to the process of
interactive maps.
So this is a thing that
we're going to start doing,
including interactive maps
in some of our CRS products.
And later on the line, we're
going to start find a way
to do confidential
interactive maps [inaudible].
So what kind of products
do we have?
Sometimes we have a
simple reference map --
what countries are part
of the NATO alliance?
So we can make a map if
you're traveling to an area
and you just want to
see this information's,
what country's a part and
what countries aren't?
So here's a simple reference
map that we can make.
Next. We also have
industry-specific research.
One of the things here at CRS,
the librarians are pretty good
about searching for information.
So here's an example of media
outlets in a particular state.
So can I get a list of all
the newspapers, magazines,
dailies in my -- say, to
help you with outreach?
So we can go and get one
of these paper databases,
digitize it, and then
make a map for it.
And here is the result.
So you may not have access
to this information,
but at CRS, we do.
One of the great
things that we can do,
we can help you see how has
legislation changed over time?
This example we have here,
we have four different areas.
We have the Nevada test site
where they were testing
nuclear weapons.
And there was proposed
legislation
that has change over time.
The first area was this dash
box, the next where the hash is
through the counties, and
then the third were the
yellow counties.
So you can see there have been
three rounds of legislation.
How has that changed over time?
And you can see it on paper,
but sometimes seeing it
as a picture really
helps you visualize.
Another example is possible
impacts of legislation.
Everyone's heard of food
deserts where there's areas
where there are low
access to food.
But there's no clear definition.
So there are four definitions
of what a food desert is.
So if legislations pass, what
definition are they going to use
and how will that
affect the constituents?
So we will provide that to
you -- all four examples --
so you can see which way your
constituents would be affected.
Another thing we can do, we
can map areas of interest.
So here is our participation
-- precipitation --
participation of
the federal program.
So we can map them up by county,
by congressional
districts, by state.
So you can say here's a
Social Security distribution
by county throughout
United States.
And then we can also give
you a state-specific map
so you can compare your
state to other states
in the products that
we give to you.
This was mentioned earlier,
mapping constituents;
where do we have high veteran
populations in our states?
So it's a simple question,
but it's these sort of things
that we can provide to you.
So you can see instead of
this county, this county,
you can now start
seeing the clusters
of where we have
high populations
of whatever our target group
is that we're looking at.
So next I'm going to
turn the presentation
to my coworker, Hannah.
>> Hannah Fischer: Oh,
thank you so much, Calvin.
Okay. So now I'm going
to give an example
of how we combine the subject
area expertise that our analysts
and librarians have here at the
Congressional Research Service
and how we put that
together with GIS
to evaluate data sources
and to create GIS products
that are authoritative
and visually compelling
and that help Congress
navigate exactly those kinds
of really complex policy issues
that Representative
Takano mentioned.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
Oh, nope. What were you doing?
You were just --
>> Calvin DeSouza: Next.
>> Hannah Fischer: Next?
Oh. There we go.
All right.
So I'm one member
of the CRS GIS team.
And I happen to be working
with an analyst here
who works on refugee issues.
And she wanted to map all
of the migrants who had died
in the course of
their migration.
So she pointed me to a data
source that you can see here,
the Missing Migrants Project.
And as you can see, this is a
snapshot from their website.
And they have it kind of
centered on the Mediterranean.
And it's very detailed data.
It looks like a latitude
and longitude
for every migrant death.
And so I said, "All right,
let's go ahead and bring
that into our GIS and
take a look at it."
So we brought it in, and the
first thing we did was what we
know every member of Congress
is immediately going to do,
which is we went to go
look at the United States.
And when we did that,
we saw that there seemed
to be these two big
circles that are close to --
not exactly on but close
to the US/Mexico border.
And that -- that seemed
a little odd to us.
So we said, "All right.
Well, let's take a
closer look at that."
So we did a little heat
mapping and clicked directly
on the center of the heat map.
And it said, "Well,
there's 145 migrant deaths
at this exact location,
this particular longitude
and latitude."
And we thought, "Well, that
just seem very unlikely to us.
Let's look into that
a little bit more."
So we went to look at
the data's methodology.
And indeed, once
which started reading,
they do address that
exact thing.
They have this sentence
in there:
Data on the US/Mexico border
are compiled based on data
from the US county
medical examiner's
and sheriff's offices.
So essentially, data in this
area is collected differently
than in the rest of the world.
They roll it up into these
county medical examiner's
offices for this area, which
is different than the data --
excuse me -- in the
rest of the world.
Huh. So I remember
working with the analyst --
[inaudible] is the analyst, and
then our graphic specialist,
Amber Wilhelm, who I
see is also in the room.
And all kind of -- we sat
for a moment and thought
about this and said, "All right.
Well, let's go home,
sleep on it,
and we'll come back tomorrow
and we'll try again."
So then the next day we came
back and we thought, "All right,
well, maybe what we can
do is we can explain this.
We'll come up with some
kind of legend and explain
that this is a little
bit different
on the US/Mexico border."
So here are some
designed legends that kind
of explain this difference.
And then we looked at
that for a little while.
And then we thought,
"Hmm, you know what?
I think this data, it just --
right now it doesn't
meet the CRS standards."
We take very seriously the idea
that Congress could
make policy based
on the information
that we give them.
And the map as it currently is
could potentially be misleading.
If you didn't go and take a look
and really read the legend here,
you could kind of
get the wrong idea.
So right now I don't think
we can publish this map.
However, I do have good news.
So we were doing this back
at the beginning of 2017.
At that time the last full year
of data that we had was 2015.
The data for 2016 was similar.
But then for 2017 there
is a new methodology.
So as you can see here,
there's a longitude and latitude
for each missing migrant
along the US/Mexico border.
So as we get to the end
of 2017, we may be able
to revisit this issue
and perhaps look
into providing a product for
Congress in the coming year.
All right.
So other things that we're
looking into for the future
and that we're doing
at the moment.
So one thing that we're
really trying to do more
of is we're trying to put more
charts and graphs together
with maps so that you can
really explore the data
in multiple different ways and
take a deeper dive into it.
So here we have -- this is
crop cultivation in Kenya.
The dark red colors
correspond to the years
in which we have the GIS data.
And so providing it in these two
different ways hopefully allows
the viewer the space to say,
"Oh, okay, I understand this
in two different ways.
I have a deeper understanding
of this issue now."
Another thing that we're looking
into is just taking a look
at different kind of charts
and providing the information
in different kind of ways.
So in this particular
case we're taking a look
at European population.
As you can imagine,
population can change kind
of on two different axes.
So you could have what's
called here net migration.
So immigration versus
emigration.
Or you could have
a natural change.
So that's live births
in a country
versus the deaths in a country.
So we've got all of that
plotted on the chart.
So you could be -- for
instance, you could be Germany.
You could have a big growth rate
despite what is probably a lower
birth rate, and that's due
to that larger net migration.
So you have more immigration
going into the country.
Or conversely, you
could be Albania.
So you have a pretty good birth
rate versus your death rate,
but you have a lot
of emigration.
And so you have a
shrinking population overall.
So then once you
put that together
with a map using the
same color palette,
then you have two different
ways to explore this.
You have a spatial
way to explore this
and this other chart -- kind of
new chart way to explore this.
And hopefully a way to
explore this data in lots
of new and interesting ways.
So as you can see,
our GIS products
for Congress really follow
along in many of the same ways
that all of our other
products for Congress do
and keep the same values.
They are authoritative,
objective, and non-partisan.
And they are confidential
for the requester.
And hopefully they
allow the requester
to explore these issues in a --
in new and visually
compelling ways.
All right.
I think we have time
for questions
if anybody has any questions.
[ Inaudible ]
Well, as our director
mentioned, CRS is --
our work is only for
Congress at this point.
So it is -- it is
true that every --
sometimes our work
does get released
through Congressional
offices to constituents.
But right now we work
only for Congress.
[ Inaudible ]
Well, it --
>> Calvin DeSouza: It
depends on the product.
We work with you to
set the deadline.
So as soon as you put in a
request, we give you a call
and we start figuring
out what can we get
to you by your deadline?
Sometimes we may meet your first
deadline with a set of products
and then we come back
more at a later deadline.
But we can work.
Sometimes it's an
hour turnaround.
We just had a new request
today that we got yesterday.
>> Hannah Fischer: Yeah.
>> Calvin DeSouza: We
got to get [inaudible].
>> Hannah Fischer: Yeah.
So it -- it also is very
much set by the requester.
And they can request
whatever they want to request.
And then we work
within that timeframe.
[ Inaudible ]
We absolutely work with
federal agencies for their data.
And I would say that
we also work
with geography and
maps downstairs.
I see Jackie Nolan
in the audience.
She often also gets
the data from agencies.
And we work with her as
well for some of that data.
Jackie, did you want
to say anything?
Okay [Laughs].
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hannah Fischer: Yeah.
>> Calvin DeSouza: And then
our analysts have a good set
of contacts that they can
reach out to the exact person
who would be collecting
that data.
So you can go through the
Congressional office to get it,
but then sometimes
you can reach directly
out to the person
if you know them.
>> Hannah Fischer: Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Calvin DeSouza: We're
doing printed reports.
The Esri platform
that we're using is --
what's the word -- flexive?
Is that the word?
Where if we make a map,
it should be viewable
on iPad or a tablet.
But I think we're designing
mostly for desktop and tablets
and not for, like, phones.
But.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hannah Fischer: Yes?
Oh, yes.
>> Calvin DeSouza: Yeah.
>> Hannah Fischer: Yeah.
>> Calvin DeSouza: So
sometimes the House
and the Senate have
[inaudible] accounts.
Sometimes we can provide them
with the data or get them set
up on their [inaudible] account
to make the maps
on their website.
So we can package the
data, give it to them,
and then they can
serve it up themselves.
All right.
>> Hannah Fischer: Okay.
>> Calvin DeSouza: Thank you.
>> Hannah Fischer:
Well, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All right.
Thank you, again, Dr.
Mazanec and the GIS team there
at Congressional
Research Service.
We're running a bit
ahead of schedule.
So I think we'll
keep it that way
with about a 15-minute coffee
break starting right now.
We'll reconvene at 10:25.
So after the coffee break, we'll
have presentations on GIS use
in the House and Senate.
So please enjoy a 15-,
20-minute coffee break.
Thank you.
All right, everyone.
So I think we'll kick things
off again for the second half
of our morning session.
So if you can please make
your way to your seats
or diminish your
conversations a little bit.
We will next move on to
presentations on the use of GIS
in the House and the Senate.
So first I'd like to
introduce Tim Petty,
the deputy legislative director
for Senator James
E. Risch of Idaho.
And he will be discussing
the use of GIS in the Senate.
So please welcome Mr. Petty.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim Petty: Good
morning, everybody.
Thank you so much for being
able to join us this morning.
It's been a great
interactive discussion already.
Again, my name is Tim Petty.
Not only am I a legislative
assistant to Senator Risch,
but I'm also part of a
cochair of a working group.
The Senate GIS Working Group
has actually been functioning
since about 2011.
Colin and Hannah and a number
of others have actually
participated on the Senate side.
And now we also have a
House-side working group
as well.
So it's been a real
pleasure to work with a lot
of the staff since 2011.
And the whole concept behind
putting this together, I --
originally we were the --
Senate Risch and actually
Senator Blumenthal were the
first two cochairs.
And then that staffer left
and we were able to pick
up Becca Steels from
Senator Wyden.
And so the last two or
three years Senator Wyden
and Senator Risch were cochairs
of the GIS Working Group.
And so we continue to strive
to just engage the staff
on the Hill on how to
better utilize GIS.
The CRS and Library of Congress
has been a fabulous resource
for us.
As you can only go so far
and have so much time,
and many times I've
turned over and needed help
to the CRS to give us support.
So some of the questions
that were asked was
that's we as staff do.
We come to CRS for the details.
And they've been a
fabulous partner with us.
And so over the last
six or seven years,
the website that I have here --
I'm going to talk and
Bonnie's going to help me,
but she's also going to
participate a little bit in part
of the interactive discussion
of how we're actually using GIS
for my member and for
our staff and actually
for the constituents of Idaho.
So most of these different
images, the thumbnail sketches
that you see here are
actually done by a lot
of the different interns
and/or working with Esri
to help us put these
different thumbnail sketches
up of different areas of Idaho.
It's a very popular site for
a lot of our constituents
to use through the years.
And we actually get a lot
of correspondence back
from our Idaho constituents
of these resources.
So as Bonnie maybe click on
a few and just kind of open
up a few, as they open
up, it givens a little bit
of an idea how we're trying
to incorporate different type
of information back
to our constituents.
So this website is
actually built and designed
for the purpose for the
constituents of Idaho.
And so as Bonnie works through
those, it gives a little bit
of an idea of what those entail.
So one of the other
questions that I'll highlight
as Bonnie brings up
just a really recent --
our latest post that we did,
which is a story map dealing
with Boulder White-Cloud.
And one of the questions was,
"Can this actually
be implemented
to handheld devices
and/or iPhones or iPad?"
And the answer is yes.
And so if Bonnie open up
the Boulder White-Cloud,
which I'm going to kind of
go through, as you can see,
it also operates
right on the iPhone.
And so the tools that we use --
actually, everything is
underpinning by Esri,
which actually was able
through the Library of Congress
to contract so that
every member --
both House and Senate members
actually have a full access
to a web-based Esri account
that they can actually utilize.
And so when I actually go on,
build a GIS interactive
discussion,
it immediately gets put
up on my members' website,
but it's all backed in by most
of the authoritative data source
that comes from federal
agencies, and/or data.gov,
and resources that
we've been able
to gather and post these up.
So with that said, what I want
to do is Bonnie and I are going
to just kind of quickly go
through how do we interact
with policy and with GIS?
And so this was a
long-term project
that my member had been working
on through many congresses.
And this is Boulder
White-Cloud wilderness area.
And so as Bonnie goes
through, you know,
Senator Risch has
had many comments
on the floor in discussion.
And what which wanted to
do was create a story map
of the background and
history of how long it took
for this particular area
within Idaho circled there
and then blown up a little
bit larger, which is part
of the western edge of the
Rocky Mountains in Idaho
in the area called Boulder
White-Cloud wilderness area.
So we actually had one of the
interns who came and worked
for the Senator last
fall to actually do a lot
of the documentary and
writing to put this together.
So we incorporated the language
in the Sawtooth National
Recreational area
and then built these
different datasets
on this continuous
area of discussion.
So these three combination areas
and these three different
color areas talks
about three different
sections of some legislation
that took place multiple
Congresses ago.
And then what we tried
to do was go back
and actually collect
these different bills
that were actually
submitted all the way back
into the 108th Congress.
We're in the 115th now.
Every Congress session's two
years, you can do the math.
We've been working on
this policy project
for many, many years.
And it gives references,
and you can go in
and actually see the bill
and then how it has transformed
throughout years from kind
of these big globs of
circles to actually starting
to put boundaries together.
And then we give this history
of how those boundaries
were developed.
And then we talked
about the stakeholders.
And so what I would like to
do is just highlight some
of the stakeholder process.
Because the shareholders,
through the many years,
were collecting data.
A lot of town hall meetings,
a lot of the discussions
in this area for the Senator,
as well as the Congressman
that worked on this on both side
of the aisle really
went through this.
And the best part that occurred
was a few years ago we started
working with the
Governor's Office of Idaho.
And we got them involved
with the participation.
So this actual dataset that
Bonnie's going to be going
through was working with the
Governor's Office in Idaho
for them to actually
start building and looking
at a multipurpose area where
we talked about hiking trails,
and snowmobile trails, and horse
trails, and off-road vehicles,
as well as areas that would be,
then, designated as wilderness.
So it became a hugely
collaborative
stakeholder process.
And we use the GIS and
these mapping tools
to allow the different
members, both House and Senate
and my boss, to actually
taking these devices and go
out to the town hall
meetings and actually talk
about the specific
areas of the trails.
You can drill down, you can
open up and look at exactly
where these different
areas are at
and then allow the
stakeholders to give input
into what they were looking
at for a legislative bill.
And so it just became
a fantastic tool.
And so this actual
dataset resides in Idaho
in the Governor's Office.
And so through Bonnie's
help -- and I wanted, yeah,
to go back in this and ask
Bonnie a few questions of what
that took so that we could
incorporate their data
and their dataset as a
state agency to work with --
what it took to work
with, like, Forest Service
and the federal agencies
to work together
and those steps that
process through.
So if you want to talk, Bonnie,
a little bit about that process.
>> Sure. Thanks, Tim.
Basically the tools that the
House and the Senate have access
to allow you to do this sort
of private collaboration
with other users.
So, for example, using a group
within the Senate's
online account,
they can privately collaborate
with the state CIO's office
and share maps and layers
and data back and forth
without necessarily
making it public, right?
Eventually that data can
become public, as we see here.
But initially, while these kind
of policy discussions
were going on, you know,
Tim's office really
just needed access
to that authoritative
information coming
from the state level.
So the online tools
that they have access
to allow them to do that.
And so, really, any
office within the House
and the Senate can follow
the same sort of model.
>> Tim Petty: Thank you, Bonnie.
And that really became
the partnership
with really effective tools.
And it was Esri and the resource
tools of GIS that give us
that ability to constantly
throughout each of the week go
through those reiterations
going back and forth --
where the boundaries were,
where the trails are,
what part of are going
to be wilderness,
what areas were these
different --
and the different communities,
then, had the ability to see
that information, have
access to that information,
and then talk legibly about
what it is that we could
and could not do legislatively.
So with those type of resources,
it really has transformed the
way we're able to now do policy
with the state agencies,
as well as the counties
because now the counties
are starting
to also become fully engaged
with these type of resources
as well, which when you get
out into those communities,
it's all about right there
where the boots are
on the ground, right?
It's not about what's
going to happen back here.
And so from that, then we
got a final bill passed.
We have web links to the
different members talking
about the final legislation.
We actually put together
the boundaries,
which looks very
different than the images
that we had previously, right?
It really started coming
together with the details
of what this all entailed.
And then my senator
talking specifically
about the legislative and the
final bill, which then was able
to go and then President Obama
then signed the legislation
into law.
And now that's what we have,
the Boulder White-Cloud
wilderness area.
And I love the quote that
we put up here at the end
with Congressman Mike Simpson.
He said, "How do you
justify making Boulder
White-Cloud wilderness?"
I said, "I didn't.
I don't even try."
I said, "Go up there
and spend a few nights,
it justifies itself."
And that's been the best part
about not only telling a story,
but it allows, then,
the community
to really participate
in that process.
So I'm going to stop
there at this point.
And see, I think
what we're going
to do is have the
House side, Tim, right?
And you're going do introduce,
and then we'll take some
questions at the end
for both kind of the House
and the Senate side
collaboration that takes place.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All right.
Thank you, Tim and Bonnie.
So as Tim mentioned,
following the presentation
from the House we're going
to open up to questions
for both of these groups.
We have microphones on the
sides that we can pass along
to whoever's asking any question
so that we can all
hear the question
so that our video
recording can pick it up.
So next I would like
to introduce Rae Best,
the House librarian,
and Nick Schumate,
the GIS specialist
in the House Library.
And they will be
discussing the use of GIS
in the House of Representatives.
So please welcome Rae
Best and Nick Schumate.
[ Applause ]
>> Rae Best: Good morning.
We're going to go ahead
and discuss the House
and how the House uses GIS.
And a lot of the same
things that Tim said
about what was going on in
the Senate is also going on --
is this -- there we go.
Is also going on in the House.
We do have a GIS
working group meeting
that is sponsored by
the House Library.
We also teach classes
through the House Library.
The beginning introduction
to GIS is taught
in the House Learn Center.
Esri, Bonnie teaches
the other two classes,
one is constituent
correspondence
and one is story mapping.
And it's always good to go ahead
and take the introduction
class first and go
on to Bonnie's more
expert classes.
And as you can see,
I'm Rae Ellen Best.
This is Nick Schumate
and Nate Bradley.
And he will be talking
about getting a count
on the House side for GIS.
>> Nate Bradley: Good
morning, everyone.
I just wanted to let you know
that as you observe the
numerous capabilities
of the Esri platform and
software tool and to get started
with the ability to create
your own interactive map
for your office, for analytical
study, I encourage you
to call the HIR -- Human
Information Resource --
Customer Solution Service Desk.
That is where we can immediately
create an account for you.
We also have the ability -- if
you desire to get more involved
with capabilities
of the software,
we can give you software links
to an actual desktop copy
for the application tool.
So the turnaround time
for creating an account we
have is less than 24 hours.
But the team has been able
to get you established
and going a whole
lot sooner than that.
So feel free to call them
and they'll get you going.
Thank you.
>> Rae Best: Okay.
Next we're just going to talk
a little bit about HouseMAP.
Esri has branded the
GIS product in the House
of Representatives as HouseMAP.
There is a portal if you are
on the intranet in the House,
it's Library.House.gov/maps.
That has detailed information on
classes, information about CRS
and how they build maps,
the Library of Congress
cartography department
and how they can help
you with mapping.
So it is just a very
nice portal for HouseMAP.
GIS is used in the House to
show policy just like Senator --
Representative Takano
said today on the national
and on the district level in
the House of Representatives.
The district interests
are very important.
A lot of members gather
constituent correspondence,
and then they map out that
constituent correspondence.
And Nick will be showing
you a great example
of the Reagan National
Airport noise map today.
And just visually communicating
with maps and getting in touch
with your constituents
and showing them
that you're interested
in certain issues
that they're interested in.
So we're just going to --
we're going to go through,
I'm going to take
five representatives
and show you some
of the things and --
representatives and committees
and some maps from Esri.
And Nick will do another five.
And this map is Lou Barletta,
Congressman from Pennsylvania
11th Congressional District.
He does Main Street tours,
sort of like Representative
Takano's map of businesses.
He just stops by and talks with
people in his community and goes
through different counties
and different towns.
Right here he is stopping by
the local library and looking
at the books in the collection.
He's stopped by another --
a unique little store
called Eclectic Envy
in downtown Danville.
He stopped by to discuss
historic preservation
of this site in Pennsylvania.
So it really just shows him out
and about talking
to the community.
And he has a nice way of
just giving a little synopsis
about his visits and also
meeting with the shopkeepers
or when he's visiting fire
stations with the firemen
and taking pictures with them.
Okay, another thing that
Congressman Lou Barletta does
of Pennsylvania 11th District
is he has his outreach hours.
So he never wants any of his
constituents to be too far
from a place where somebody
can hear their concerns.
So he's done push pins as
the symbols in this map.
And so the blue push pins are
other outreach besides his
official outreach offices.
This one is Karen
Boback's office.
And she's actually a state
representative for Pennsylvania.
And it tells you her
hours, where she's located,
etc. The red pins are
his official office --
this one, okay -- is
his official offices.
I don't know why this is not --
and so his office are open
from -- I'm not sure why,
this isn't doing it the right
way; okay, there we go --
9:00 to 5:00 at all times.
He also gives a nice detail
at the bottom of this map,
gives you information about
all the district offices,
where you can go
and see outreach.
And then at the very end he has
his official outreach offices,
of course, his office
in Washington,
D.C. and his other official
offices, district offices.
Next one of the -- Mike Johnson,
which was a freshman member
in the 115th Congress,
made a pledge
to have a commitment
to civility.
And he asked members on
both side of the aisle
to sign this commitment
that they will be civil
to each other, civil, you
know, in conferences, you know,
on committees, etc. And
this is a map of people
who have either signed
the commitment
or have mentioned the
commitment on the floor speech,
etc. So like I said,
this is bipartisan.
So you have Republicans.
And this was just for
the freshmen coming on.
But a few seasoned Congressman
and Congresswoman have also
signed this commitment.
And here you can see
John Lewis who has been
in the House for a while.
This is probably one of
the most complex maps we're
showing today.
And this is from the
Committee on Natural Resources.
And it is -- it's actually
divided by districts,
which is very important in
the House of Representatives.
We do everything by district.
And this is different natural
resources in people's districts.
So this is the great sand dunes.
This is another protected area.
I don't know why it's --
It's just taking a
long time [inaudible].
So I don't know -- so this
is actually when it says one
of twelve, there's actually
twelve other information boxes
here that just aren't loading.
It is actually a complex map,
so maybe today it's just
not loading as quickly.
This is some information
about the continental shelf
and it being off limits to
oil and gas development.
So this is just a really nice
map on -- on natural resources.
Actually, it isn't all the
way loaded because I was going
to show you the legend.
Like, the pink areas
are protected lands;
yellow might be the
Bureau of Natural Lands,
etc. But I'll just
show you the layers
because for some reason
the legend is not showing
on this presentation.
So these are the
different layers.
One thing that we usually use
in the House is this layer,
which is 115th Congressional
District, which tells you
about the Congressman --
a little bit about
the Congressman,
if they're a Republican
or Democrat,
usually what district
they're in.
Also tells you the
square mileage --
square miles of their district.
So it's a good place to
get that information.
And this is just all the
other layers on this map,
wild and scenic rivers, critical
habitat of endangered species,
the Bureau of Land
Management, Forest Service.
Okay, I'm going to go
on to the next map.
This is a map that Esri made I'm
assuming somewhere around 2012
after Sandy hit the east coast.
And this is a good
example of a slide map.
Some of you remember New
Jersey and Seaside, New Jersey,
the amusement park at the beach?
And so here's the figure
eight for the racecars,
here's the roller coaster,
here's the parking lot.
And just with this slide map it
just shows you the devastation.
There's no parking lot anymore.
Nothing sort of shows you quite
like a map and the visualization
of before and after pictures.
Some of you remember seeing the
roller coaster during high tide
actually in the water.
There's no figure
eight here anymore.
You know, the road is
completely sanded over.
Another example is before.
And this is in Mantoloking,
New Jersey
and actually breaking completely
through the peninsula
all the way
into the intercoastal waterway.
And last is the Statue of
Liberty, a nice picture
of the Statue of Liberty
on a bright, sunny day.
And then after Sandy, you
couldn't even get there
because the pier had been
completely wiped away.
Okay? I'm going to
hand this over, then,
to Nick to show you five other
examples of how it is used
in the House -- how GIS
is used in the House.
>> Nick Schumate:
Thank you, Rae.
Hey, everybody.
How's it going?
Good. That's what
I want to hear.
Okay. So here's a good example.
So Rae talked earlier
about constituent
correspondence in the House.
Don Beyer actually made
a really good map here.
He did a heat map of
correspondence in his district
in regards to noise complaints
about Reagan National Airport.
So you can see here that what
he's done is he has created --
let me get that out of the
way for you -- he's created --
so you can see the
centers of issues,
and it kind of gives you
a visual representation
of where the noise is being
consolidated and where a lot
of people are having
issues with it.
But what he did is he took it
and made a story map out of it.
So you could go through
here if you want to,
but it's basically just
describing the issue,
putting it in more detail, and
then he kind of gives solutions
that he's provided for
the reasons he's bringing
up legislation in regards to it
and why he's approaching
it the way he does.
So this is all embedded
on his website
so his constituents can
better understand the issue
and what he's doing for it.
So he's gotten a lot of detail
here, but he actually shows
that he embeds videos and
he's got news articles.
And he's just got basically
everything you could possibly
want about it right here.
Even his Twitter right here.
So it's just a good way to
consolidate information,
create sort of a narrative,
and better tackle
the subject matter.
So here's one, Representative
McSally, Martha McSally.
She went on a hike in the
Arizona National Scenic Trail.
This is more of just kind of
a fun one that she made here.
And, again, this is a story map.
And if it loads, it's going to
show as you go down the list --
so on the left side
here it's going
to show pictures that she took.
But on the right side it's
going to correlate to the part
of the trail she was on.
So you can almost, like, go
on a journey with her and see
where each picture was
taken, what was going on.
Again, there's a video here.
And as you keep going down,
it's going to show
the legs of the trail.
I think it's 800 miles.
I don't know if she did the
whole thing but -- not yet?
Okay, yeah [Laughs].
I couldn't do that,
Jesus [Laughs].
Anyhow, so she just goes
through and kind of maps it out.
And so you can see, you
know, how the trail goes
and where she's gone on it
and everything like that.
So it's just kind of a
fun way to communicate
with her constituency.
As Mark Takano spoke
earlier, he showed a few maps.
And I think they mentioned the
Title I funding and API scores.
So Title I being low-income
families in his district.
And he kind of compares
it to academic success.
And it's really great because
it's got the two maps here.
And this is another
policy issue, obviously.
And as you move one
map, it moves the other.
And if you zoom in, it
does the same thing.
And so it's a good way to
create two data sources
and bring them together.
It's a good way of
visualizing it.
It's hard to do otherwise.
So the visualization
really kinds
of accentuates the point here.
Another one from Takano.
Actually, he mentioned
a little bit about this,
but he went on this
weird and wonderful tour.
Basically it just shows a lot
of the hotspots in his district.
I won't go through all of them.
But there's, like, music
venues, theatres, racetracks.
It gives a little bit more
information about each one.
So you could go through here
and his constituents could go
through here and just see what
he's highlighting and what kind
of cool things there are
to do in the district.
So it's just a fun way to
engage with the constituency
and also provide more insight.
The last one I'm going to show
here is actually one Esri made.
It's about healthcare.
So basically it's
comparing access to doctors
with access to healthcare.
And what you can do is --
the data's a little old,
but you get the idea.
It's the slider here
is showing --
on the left side it's showing
the doctor office accessibility;
on the right it's
doing healthcare.
So you could also -- you
know, this is sort of like
when you're putting
those two maps
but you're actually
overlaying them.
And it's a good way to
compare as Rae showed
with the Hurricane Sandy.
So it's a good way to kind
of create a different sort
of visualization that really
helps accentuate the points
you're trying to get at.
So those are just some examples
that the House has encountered
and has come up in
our class as well.
So this is just our
contact information.
Again, I'm Nick,
this is Rae, Nate.
I think we're going
to be doing Q&A.
So [inaudible] take it over.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge:
Thank you very much.
That was excellent
presentation, thank you.
So at this point we'll open up
to questions for both the House
and the Senate groups.
We'll be passing around these
microphones on the side.
But if you have any questions
for either of these groups,
please just raise your hand.
We'll pass the microphone
to you.
>> Very brief --
very brief question.
Tim Petty mentioned that you can
follow the maps on your iPhone.
My question is do you
need an Apple app for that
or can you also follow those
maps on an Android phone?
>> Tim Petty: I would
probably look at Bonnie,
but I'm pretty sure
you can do it on both.
Both of them work well on both
an Android as well as an iPhone.
And so we were very
pleased with it.
And actually, my chief of staff
uses it much more when he's
out in the field than
what my member does.
My member prefers the iPad, but
he actually also put an Esri app
that actually renders
even quicker
than if he just Googles it.
And so but you can
just go straight
to the Senator's website
and go into his map gallery,
and all of those different
renderings come up,
at least on my iPhone.
I don't have an Android to
test it, but I'm pretty sure
that both of them
are interchangeable.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Okay. I'm not entirely sure
who this question
should be directed at,
but I was just wondering, so
the CRS people were talking
about how, like, the office
can request a map to be made
and then they'll make it.
But for the Representative
and Senate staffers,
it sounded like y'all had a lot
of interaction with
making the maps.
And so I guess I was wondering
if maybe somebody could explain
that a little bit more.
Like, how much involvement does
the staff have with map-making?
>> Nick Schumate:
All right, sure.
So what we're doing is
we're providing the tools
to kind of create yourself.
I know that Esri helps
out member offices
if they have requests.
We are offering kind of
the tools for each office
to kind of do it themselves.
But sometimes that goes beyond
our scope and their scope
of the data that they need.
And so that's going to get
where you're kind of treading
that line between can
you do it yourself
or do you need professional
CRS support?
And I'm sure CRS can
talk more about that.
But they kind of provide
the more authoritative data,
whereas we're giving you the
tools to access that data.
So it's kind of if you need
the information researched
and need it, you know, put
together in that format
versus doing it yourself.
>> Tim Petty: Yeah, and
that's actually perfect.
And so that combination,
so there's some scopes
where I've really need some
specific details from my member.
And so I actually called Jim and
Hannah and Colin and said hey --
and went over their
office and said this is --
I don't even know how
to go about doing this,
but this is an end result.
And they were fantastic.
And they gave me a
first set of datasets.
And I was able to
look at these maps
that they specifically
had in an issue an Idaho.
And they said we're going to
take a little bit more time.
But I was able to ice
that for my member
and then give them more
information as they were able
to develop and kind
of build out.
And it had to do with
a boundary issue.
And so they actually went
back and worked with even some
of the federal agencies
to help understand
where the boundaries were,
which was part of the question.
And so that was a fantastic
resource that's way beyond even
a lot of staff's scope.
And trying -- that's part what
the working groups are also
about on the House and
the Senate, is to say,
"Try it as far as I can,
but if you need help,
then there's amazing people
that understand maps and GIS
that can carry it
the rest of the way."
>> Rae Best: I just wanted
to add one other thing is
when you get your password,
you're in a community.
I work for the Office
of the Clerk
of the House of Representatives.
So that's our umbrella
community.
But we have made
subset communities
in the House Library.
So if we're working on a map,
we can give other librarians
permission to view that map,
criticize it, or add to,
etc. so that it lets you --
the GIS software
platform is just
so powerful it lets you make
subsets that you can, you know,
work on maps with other people
in your office or
your committee.
>> Can you talk a little
bit about what the committee
on natural resources -- on how
they're using this type of tool
with their -- with their
legislation and policy concerns
since it's so detailed?
>> Rae Best: I probably
can't tell you too much
about what they do.
We're just sort of illustrating
what the committees are doing
in the House.
And so you can go on their
committee page and look and see
if they have a map gallery.
And the map that I showed
you didn't completely load
because it's an extremely
complex map with regulations
on it about not, you know,
drilling in certain areas,
etc. So if you go online
and look at that map,
it will give you some
idea of what policies
and what they're looking at, and
other maps that they're doing,
and, you know, other policies
that they're looking at.
>> Tim Petty: And I might be
able to follow up a little bit,
at least on the Senate side,
which there are several staff
on the Energy Natural Resource
Committee on the Senate
who actually come to
our working group.
Anne Hoefler actually
has a background in GIS.
And so I know she's made
a number of requests
and has worked, actually,
with Esri and with Department
of Interior to help them
-- energy maps, line maps,
pipelines, those kind of areas,
federal lands specifically
to get pretty detailed.
And I actually know that there's
a professional staff, Chance,
from the Senate Commerce
Committee who's
out here somewhere that
also is participating
in continually developing
background.
And his background
also is in GIS.
So, of course, he's
a younger staffer.
And those are the
greatest resources
that you usually can tap into.
Because they've actually had
the education and training
and they're bringing
it to those committees
and really have some great
resources to facilitate.
So I'm excited of even where
the committees are heading,
at least on the Senate side
with utilizing these resources.
>> We have a question
over here in back.
>> You mention that you
had feedback or comments
from other individuals when
working on a map or you share it
with someone for
feedback; is there a way
that you track it internally,
like, on comments like you do
in SharePoint point or in Word,
or is there a feature in there
that allows you to do
that or activate it?
>> Tim Petty: Yeah.
So with that, if I might because
I think you -- on the same is --
at least on the Senate same,
which is the Sam's website,
there's actually interactive.
Bonnie actually created a
how-to utilize some resources.
So our offices uses its
constituent resources' IQ.
And so we can data
mine that dataset
and really get good input
from constituent responses,
which is what we used with
the Boulder White-Cloud
and some other projects as well,
is those datasets that come
from the constituents who
communicate through all means
of communication -- email,
faxes, telephone conversations
when they call into the offices,
and from our state office
that put everything
into that resource.
And then we can data
mine kind of our own data
in our interactions with our
constituency to the extent
that Bonnie has helped us
to actually give the --
like, down to zip code.
So we can actually see
where they're talking about
and from what why are they
actually dealing with that issue
because that's their backyard.
Or are they discussing it just
because they're interested
in the issue 300 miles away.
So we can get that reference and
use heat maps to actually know
and really hear what's
happening to those people
in that local community.
>> Nick Schumate: I just --
sorry, just want to follow up.
One last thing is
that our GIS platform
that Esri provides
also access to,
it's almost like its
own little community.
So, again, we're opposite
the clerk, but we're all part
of the House of Representatives
in our side.
And so we can see what other
offices are publishing,
and who's publishing
them, and what comments
and suggestions and
descriptions.
And so it's almost like
social media, I guess,
maybe is an interesting
way to put it.
But it's this whole
network that you can kind
of see what everyone
else is creating.
So.
>> We have a question over here.
>> Is the Senate Library
involved in a similar way
as the House in terms of
putting these tools --
making these tools
available or being part
that have working group?
>> Tim Petty: So
maybe Jeff could help.
He's with the Senate
Sergeant at Arms.
And so with our working
group, when someone wants
to have access to
their accounts,
they can facilitate that.
The Senate side library
probably ties into all
of Library of Congress.
So I'll let Mary talk about
that a little bit more.
>> Mary Mazanec: Can I put
you on the spot, Jessica?
[ Laughter ]
>> I work in the Senate Library.
>> Mary Mazanec: Okay.
>> We're not currently
doing anything with GIS,
but that's part of [inaudible].
>> We had a question
in the back?
>> Over here.
[ Inaudible ]
>> I sort of have -- I guess
it's a data integrity question.
So I gathered from this morning,
you know, there's a lot of time
and effort and expertise
that goes
into creating these datasets.
I was looking kind of
at the Reagan example;
is there anything that you
kind of work with offices
to ensure they're using
the data properly?
Because as we all know,
you know, hotspots,
that's the analysis,
all these things.
You can really make that data
look however you want it.
So is there kind of any -- do
you just hand the data off,
or do you work with the offices
and make sure they're using it
properly in its intended use?
>> Nick Schumate: I mean,
for our office obviously
we don't have any oversight
over that.
But when we're teaching the
classes, what we tell them is
that it's almost like when
you're writing a paper
for school, cite your sources
and make sure you're
using good sources.
Same thing, we show how to
get authoritative sources
through the system we provide.
But, again, you could take
data and make your own data.
It's really up to the office.
And you just kind of want to see
where they're getting
their data from,
and that should be
fairly transparent.
But, again, it's up to
each office to do that.
So.
>> Question about
archiving of maps either
for the House or the Senate.
I'm thinking of the historical
map about the wilderness area
in Idaho, what happens to that
once the senator maybe didn't
have it on their
website anybody else
or maybe that's not a Senate --
the person isn't
a senator anymore.
What happens to that
great material?
>> Mary Mazanec: After every
Congress the National Archives
gathers every member's
website and they would --
if it is embedded in their
website, it will be captured.
So that goes with
committees and with members.
>> How would I find that, then?
>> Mary Mazanec: You just
go on the National Archives.
They have it by year and
by member or by committee.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hi. Can you please talk
about your respective
GIS working groups
and how often you meet?
And I'm assuming that these
are open to staff and members.
And kind of an example of
the topics you present.
>> Mary Mazanec: Okay.
Ours is a lot newer
than the Senate's.
So we've been doing it what,
for about a year now,
a year and a half.
We meet about three
or four times a year.
A lot of times since the
House is just getting started
with GIS, we do a lot
of just foundation type
of how to build a map.
CRS comes, Hannah's
at our meetings.
The Congressional Cartography
Division of the Library
of Congress will also come.
Sometimes we invite guest
speakers from federal agencies
that have been using
GIS for a long time
to give a demonstration
on how they're using GIS.
And yes, it is correct, members
can come, staffers can come.
And we pretty much welcome --
you know, I show up
at the Senate one,
people from the Senate also show
up at the House working group.
>> Tim Petty: So we've been
working a little bit longer
on this, since about 2011,
which there were four
of us that came together.
And we just stared at
each other and said,
"So what are we going to do?"
So the Senate side has tried
to do several different models
over the last several years.
But what seems to be
the most effective
for us is what we tried to
do, as well as what the House,
is we try to bring in an
Executive Branch agency
to kick it off for the hour.
We try to do it about every,
what, quarterly or so,
three or four times year,
four times a year,
sometimes we do five.
We definitely incorporate
in February
when there's the
federal conference here
that Esri puts on.
So they've been super in
allowing basically any
of the staff to come up over
to the federal conference.
And then there's tons of classes
that they provide that a lot
of staff will participate in
for over two or three days.
And that's extremely helpful.
But most of the staff,
for the most part,
are wanting to just
learn how to use it.
And so it's more of a how-to.
So we kick it off with
someone presenting
from the Executive Branch.
We bring in an agency.
And then what we try to do
is have a staffer, then,
present one of their
most recent developments
and how they did it, how they
screwed it up, allow other staff
to interact on what maybe
they could do that might be
or insightful to them.
Obviously we talk about
data sources and where
in the heck did you get that?
And so we really
encourage the use of that.
And since we when
live website-wise
with Esri providing the
whole back end, there's ways
and training to know what's
authoritative data sources.
It's actually coming
from data.gov.
So we really try to emphasize
on the Senate-side staff,
if you just take
the federal data,
that's who your member
has oversight over.
And so if you have questions,
then you go and find out from
that dataset who's producing
that information and where.
And then we really
encourage them to go find
that staff person
in the Executive Branch that's
been putting that data together.
So those are kind of
things that have unfolded
over a while, six years now.
So on the Senate side we've been
doing it for a little while.
I have a list of a
little over 100 staff.
We probably average 15
to 20 at every gathering,
and people come when they can.
>> Anyone else?
Well, let's give a big hand
again to our folks [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All right.
Thank you, again, Tim Petty,
Nick Schumate, Rae Best,
and Nate Bradley
for presentations
and for a really informative
question and answer session.
Unfortunately, at this point
Congressman Bruce Westerman has
had cancel.
He was pull away to a
committee meeting as happens.
So that leaves us with an
extra long lunch break.
So we will be breaking for
lunch until 1:00 o'clock.
That's when we will be moving to
GIS for the digital humanities.
So that will talk about digital
humanities, data visualization,
and story maps being
created here in the Library.
So a lot of you I know
are very excited about.
So, again, 1:00 p.m. we'll
be meeting back in this room.
If you're visiting the Library
and need some lunch options,
our cafeteria is just a couple
doors down right outside.
We also have a bunch
of restaurants along
Pennsylvania Avenue
and along First Street outside.
So, again, thank you so much
to all our presenters
for the morning.
We'll be back at 1:00 o'clock
for our afternoon session
right here in this room.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.